Allah is discussing The issue
of using words properly This is
extremely important First, last
week, we discussed What words
to use and what words not to
use? Right? A general
prohibition of using words that
are lowly, that are profane,
that are vulgar, and a general,
encouragement to use words that
are sound and eloquent and so
forth. Now, we come into a very
unique chapter which is a
chapter that honestly his heart
you'd you'd be hard pressed to
find in another book and that
is the issue of not only using
proper words and not using
words that are improper but
also using those words to
properly describe what it is
you are describing. And not
overusing words because when
overuse words, what happens? We
render them, we render them
meaningless, right? What makes
a pearl valuable? It's rarity.
The fact that it's rare. If
pearls were everywhere, they
would not have much value. If
diamonds were everywhere, as
useful as diamonds are,
industrially, if they were
everywhere, they would not have
much value. What makes these
things valuable is their
rarity. The fact that they're
rare and so, words are very
similar. It is not permissible.
Not the of the prophet to use
words that are good and clean
and pure to describe things or
name people that are not
according to those names. So,
for instance, the prophet
prohibited that a person
referred to a hypocrite as say
it. Say it in the Arabic
language means someone who is
is someone who is noble,
someone of nobility, someone of
honor. Actually, it could very
well be translated as sir. Sir,
it usually means say it. But
now, that's a good example. The
word sir. Does it really have
any meaning? I mean, we use it
to be cordial, right? But does
it have any meaning in itself?
If someone calls you sir, do
you walk around with your head
held high after that? Right?
No, it's just, it really
doesn't have much meaning
because we call everybody, sir,
right? So, what happens when we
overuse a word improperly, we
render it less rare. And when
it is rare, when it is, when it
is you know, when when our
words are saturated with it,
and it's not rare. And it's not
unique. It it has very little
meaning. So, for instance, in
Islamic titles, there are names
such as Usteth and Hafath and
Sheikh. These words have very
little meaning now. Because we
overuse them. Pretty much
anyone who has a beard wears a
thou, will call him Sheikh,
right? Anyone who memorizes the
Quran or memorizes a portion of
it will probably refer to him
as half of right? What stabbed
is anyone? Who stands in front
of a class? We call him Mustad
but these words in the history
of Islam, the way that the
scholars use these words
traditionally, actually are
words that are extremely Noble.
So, the word half of would
never be used for anyone who
has not memorized at least 100,
000 narrations. This person,
that is the bare minimum
criteria to be referred to as a
half of. The word was extremely
rare in the history of Islam
when referencing scholars
because it was so difficult to
reach that level. It's
mentioned that a person must
perfect at least 14 independent
sciences in Islamic
in Islamic disciplines to be
referred to as and it was used
to refer to scholars such as
Ibn Huzema, the great Muhadith.
Likewise, the word Sheikh,
Sheikh was a word that you
would articulate, immense
respect and nobility. Has very
little meaning now because
these words have been overused.
When we overuse words, or when
we over emphasize, what happens
is, our our words, our speech
becomes weak. And weak speech,
and inarticulate speech,
articulates,
weakness in mind
The stronger a person's speech
is, the better they are able to
speak, the more articulate they
are, this articulates
intelligence. And a lack of
good speech and proper
articulation, this
this communicates a lack of
thought and a lack of
intelligence and a people will
become more and more weak, the
more weak there, their speech
is. The more intricate of
speech, we see the more
intricate the society. But how
do we overuse words in our
time? For instance, in America,
especially in American English,
we overuse words and we render
these words meaningless. we
will use hyperbole and this
harms the language. So, we say
things. I go and eat some
chicken somewhere. I say, this
is the best, tastiest chicken
I've ever had anywhere at all
times. So, what am I going to
say when I eat something that's
better? Right? I blunt my
speech when I do that. I
probably is dangerous for for
language. Likewise, a lack of
vocabulary is dangerous for
thought and it's been positive
by many linguists and scholars
and this is articulated very
well in the book 1984 by George
Orwell that one way to control
a person's mind is to control
their language. If you teach a
people how to speak a certain
way, you actually control how
they think. and by limiting a
person's speech, you will limit
a person's intelligence and
freedom of thought. And that's
actually very accurate. And in
his book, 1984.
basically mentions a scenario
where the government wishes to
be overbearing and controlling
of every little thing that each
person does and so they one of
the ways that they do this is
they take the dictionaries
which basically is the sum of
all vocabulary and and any
particular time and they start
to change the words and take
away the richness of the
English language. And So, a
dictionary that would have
50000 words, they trim it down
to 40thousand. They trim it
down to 30000. They trim it
down to twenty thousand. So,
where people are no longer able
to articulate depth. Right?
They're not able to articulate
shades of meaning and this will
limit their free thinking.
They'll no longer be able to
think and express and put their
finger on those feelings that
they have. This extremely
dangerous. and I I'm not sure
if there's ever been in the
history of humanity a time when
language is most weak. amongst
people in general than the time
we're living in. And we can
thank social media for that and
we can thank
in articulate people that we
listen to. So, the presidential
debates in the time of Lincoln.
how four scores than seven
years ago. The these were at a
college level. The Obama
debates which were considered
to be very high caliber. We're
actually at a sixth grade
level. 6th grade. That was the
language used. Anything more
than that people won't
understand what you're saying.
This is alarming because it
means people's thoughts has
become very weak. and the
average person can speak and
read at about a fifth or sixth
grade level in America. This is
seriously disturbing
information. And it is an
unacceptable for the Muslim to
submit his mind and his free
thought. This is one of the
most important things and gifts
that we have been given by
Allah That the Quran is our
minds from the bondage of of
false authority The Quran, the
Sunnah has taught us to
liberate our thoughts, to
question authority, to think
for ourselves. And it's
expanded our minds all the way
to the cosmos, the Quran.
However, spelling is atrocious
in our time Words are used
overused to the point that in
order to exclaim things, people
are resorting to profanity,
right?
[Silence]
be judged for A person will be
ultimately judged. Based on the
meanings that are articulated,
not necessarily the sounds that
a person makes. The meanings
that are articulated. This is
what's intended by speech. So,
for instance, we have this very
hypocritical way of censoring
speech. So, if you're watching
a program for instance, right?
You're watching a program with
subtitles. And they will say
something profane. Use some
kind of profanity. And in the
subtitles, it will have like
the first letter and then the
rest will be you know, stars or
you know, different different
symbols and different
characters, right? And this is
censoring. That is the same as
just saying it because that's
what we understood when we read
it. Correct? That's exactly
what we understood. Your mind
as well write it out. As a
matter of fact, leaving things
to people's imagination could
actually be worse. Then
outright saying things. Let me
give you an example. A person
doesn't want to backbite
someone.
Allah
I
[Silence]
opens the mind to just kind of
swim in open waters of
imagination, that actually
could be very much worse than
the actual thing that the
person did. As a person starts
to all kinds of wild things and
usually as human beings, as
pessimistic human beings, we
to go to the most terrible
thing that comes to mind.
That's what we usually start
with when it comes to evil.
This
is a type of, a type of
the